[Musique]
il
qui
[Musique]
bonjour christelle évidemment bonjour
merci d'être présente sur le plateau de
ce vip
jean-luc madec bonjour j'ai environ mais
aussi aux sites être présents sur le
plateau
vous êtes là tous les deux parce que
vous avez un point commun au moins un
que je connaisse après on verra
vous êtes là parce que bientôt ce a lieu
une
un événement le 19 octobre qui va
s'appeler qui s'appelle déjà dit moi
entre entrepreneurs wrecked acteurs
culturels
voilà alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
vous êtes tous des dieux vous êtes tous
les deux à evry noir vous êtes actif sur
ce la région département par dont vous
vous êtes de montigny vous vous êtes
d'elancourt
alors depuis un an vous avez une société
christelle évidemment qui s'appelle
impulsion impulsion et qui consiste en
quoi
alors déjà impulsion a été créée par
trois dirigeants
elles consistent avant vous dont moi
d'accord
robert cadalbert ouais c'est un
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin et rem
et pierre pour eux qui est le président
des amitiés internationales andré
malraux la club culture alors impulsion
qu'il ya un an racontez moi quel est le
alors je nous avons créé la marque
culturelle art partage points comme
m'étais dollar dans vos affaires nous
rapprocherons le monde économique des
entreprises nous avons créé deux
collectifs un collectif d'artistes et un
collectif d'entreprises alors qu'au val
horizon
ces deux collectifs dans un lien qui
pour nous est très important le partage
la convivialité et le lien très fort
dans la promotion artistique nous sommes
agent artistique et dans le concept nous
une entreprise parraine un artiste
hockey devient son parrain ouais avec
nous avec un partage points comme nous
nous promotion cet artiste est ce qui
est très important dans ce concept c'est
que le coeur de métier de l'entreprise
rae a un lien avec la création
artistique d'aliens avec la création de
l'artiste
ok alors on reviendra après sur le
fonctionnement pour les artistes qui
nous regardent les entrepreneurs qui
nous regardent et qui seraient
intéressées doivent bien expliquer ça en
attendant jean lui madec je reviens vers
vous dont vous faites partie d'une
association comme on a dit qu'ils
s'appellent art partage non l'âge désert
c'est christelle abete d'accord excusez
moi qui ai fait 15 ans oui c'est ça
qu'est ce que c'est cette adaptation
association large hasard été créé par
une personnalité haute en couleurs qui
s'appelle lisent le provost qui est une
ancienne cadre de la chambre de commerce
de versailles et qui depuis toujours a
souhaité favoriser le lien entre
l'entreprise et l'artiste ont par le
monde économique et le monde artistique
et culturelle alors bon il se trouve que
des problèmes de santé ont amené lise à
prendre un petit peu de recul et elle
m'a demandé d'avoir la gentillesse de
m'occuper de cette association est de la
préside et j'en suis donc pas dans le
président délégué et l'association arche
des arcs est une association loi de 1901
à but non lucratif a toujours eu pour
fonction essentielle de favoriser ce
rapprochement entre le monde économique
et le monde artistique
tout le monde sait aujourd'hui en france
que nous avons un problème de
financement de l'art et de la culture et
donc il faut que nous puissions
communiquer aux entreprises ce besoin
que la france a que notre société on de
développer les l'art et la culture et de
pouvoir faire en sorte que l'entreprise
et pas seulement les très grandes
entreprises mais aussi les moyennes
puisse contribuer au financement de
l'art d'accord donc vous êtes
complémentaires etc voilà alors rien
trouvé
le 19 octobre qu'est ce qui se passe
concrètement alors en fait de 19 octobre
sur le plan logistique
nous nous avons choisi un lieu que je
connais bien leur vécu pendant 25 ans
c'est la commanderie des templiers de la
vie lieu à elancourt qui est un lieu
dont la vocation depuis le début depuis
sa création à la fin des années 70 et de
développer l'art et la culture
malheureusement il sauf que pour des
raisons
multiples mais en particulier par faute
de financement des collectivités
publiques
ce lieu n'a pas pu s'exprimer pleinement
dans la vocation qui est du avait été
donnée par conséquent ayant vécu moi
dans une espèce de friche culturelle
pendant 25 ans j'ai trouvé que c'était
ça pardonne fraîche pas parce que en
fait la vocation culturelle du lieu n'a
pas été suffisamment exprimé aux
questions d'exposition c'est une
vocation pas question est égal on
t'accueille d'accueil des artistes dans
le cadre d'ateliers président sur
l'image qu'ils s'étaient eux absolument
extraordinaire bon alors maintenant nous
avons grâce d'ailleurs aux relations que
nous pouvons avoir avec christelle avec
robert cadalbert qui était le patron de
la ville nouvelle pendant 16 ans est
bien considéré qu' il fallait donner
peut-être une nouvelle impulsion
c'est le cas de le dire aso et le
resteront à l'intérieur de marche très
bien ce que c'est un des restaurants aux
tenues très connues même de la ville
nouvelle et même au delà puisque on fait
de la clientèle de ce restaurant vient
de paris jusqu'à charte à peu près et
donc c'était un peu dommage que cette
locomotive qui a le restaurant les
templiers ne puisse pas aussi contribuer
au développement des rencontres
culturelles et artistiques au sein de la
commanderie donc en fait au sein d'un
bâtiment dont
l'utilité est reconnu par tous mais mal
exprimé alors voilà premier épisode
alors voilà action réaction d'accord
donc le 19 ça vous allez commencer par
une première exposition j'imagine y aura
plusieurs artistes qu'elle va se passer
alors le 19 octobre
ça va se passer ça va se dérouler en
trois temps oui en fait on va avoir une
première partie de conférences le
témoignage puisque l'année dernière on a
lancé le concept de nos rencontres nos
premières rencontres culturelles
donc là on va avoir cette partie
conférence où on va parler de
défiscalisation puisqu'aujourd'hui le
niveau d'information sur la
défiscalisation n'est pas le même pour
une tpe une pme est une grande
entreprise d'accord donc on a ce souhait
là avec jean-luc déjà qu'elle est
d'expliquer les mécanismes fiscaux de
l'accessibilité à l'art et puis après
des témoignages très important puisqu'on
a déjà commencé à travailler entre nos
artistes et nos et nos parrains
entreprises prévues vécu déjà du vécu
important pour convaincre d'autres
personnes et puis d'autres entreprises
ensuite un deuxième temps puisque la
vocation d'art partage aussi dans ces
rencontres culturelles ces deux
scénographes il a alors j'entends
scénographié aujourd'hui quand on va à
une exposition on voit là on la regarde
et nous uniquement c'est à dire qu'on
voit l'oeuvre
ouais et au sein de notre concept on
souhaite mettre en avant les cinq sens
développer le goût développé le toucher
donc on scénographie on a des comédiens
on a une équipe on a de la musique
ce qui fait que on vous plonge dans une
ambiance artistique ont tout ça dans le
toutes les oeuvres d'art ont été
exposées dans ce dans ce lieu que ce
soit dans la chapelle dans la
salle des gardes donc on va avoir une
déambulation vous en dit pas plus ce
sera la surprise
et puis le troisième temps qu est un
moment fort qui est en fait l'art
culinaire où on va avoir au sein du
restaurant alors seul à ce moment là oui
c'est un c'est un cas très fière que le
troisième temps est un temps de
convivialité aurelio mélanger canton
avec les langes avec 102 meilleur
ouvrier de france grâce à jean luc qui
sont qui sont des amis on va avoir des
ateliers autour de l'osmothèque on va
avoir les chocolats on va voir une
sculpture sur glace une fois mais une
première fois une première première
voilà et après c'est l'art c'est ouvert
au public ou non est ouvert aux
entreprises en entreprise
on a évidemment l'ambition d'abord là on
appelle bien entrepreneurs acte cultuel
la saison 1 épisode 1
on espère évidemment que au sein de
cette commanderie qui est un lieu
particulièrement privilégié pour pouvoir
faire se rencontrer ces deux mondes
glaciaire qui sont évidemment appelé à
ou ceux reliés alors évidemment par
havana finances parce que quelque part
ce qu'on veut c'est pas un commentaire
de la guerre mais justement alors
christelle comment vous choisissez vos
artistes comment faire si on est artiste
et si on a envie de faire partie de
votre vivier si je puis dire
les artistes on connaissait d'avants
puissants que ça fait dix ans que je
suis dans le monde culturel una normes
et vous vous renouvelez j'imagine on se
renouvelle les artistes viennent à
travers des dynamiques d'entreprise ce
et j'explique jeu j'ai rencontré l'autre
jour une société qui est intéressé par
le concept et qui me dit mais moi dans
mes amis je connais une artiste en fait
aujourd'hui je suis je suis la seule à
choisir ces artistes avec l'or avec mon
associé robert cadalbert et aux arts et
les artistes ont fait beaucoup de
communication et
j'ai envie de dire que la dynamique du
concept que l'on met en place attire de
nouveaux artistes travaillent maintenant
le souhait serait quand même de créer un
collectif de journalistes de critique
d'art une équipe de jury doit appeler ça
un lieu qui aident à la halle à comment
dirais-je au choix le retraitement les
entreprises vous leur proposez d'acheter
les oeuvres de les louer de les exposer
un outil en fait une fois à l'elysée
nous pas tout à fait là on a de la
location est là on peut faire du livre
d'art on peut faire de l'évènement
interne
d'accord on a organisé il ya pas
tellement longtemps une opération
ceinture base logistique une société du
territoire à la cour avec virginie
rigaud est une artiste qui est
complètement dans la verticalité et le
métier le coeur de on a exposé sur des
sur des gîtes air des palettes ont déjà
des lois sur des gîtes r en fait ce sont
des ce sont des grandes caisses de
ferraille dans lequel vous vous stocker
du matériel d'accord transporter du
matériel alors du coup pouvons imaginer
vous vous mettez en lien donc l'artiste
et l'entreprise mc que vous vous dites
tiens cela cet artiste correspond à la
dynamique de cette entreprise j'ai vu
qu'ils sont bonnes si vous aviez des
petits commentaires en fait sous des
oeuvres des artistes au pur comment dire
alors aller dans le sens de l'entreprise
c'est ça oui et aussi parce que pour moi
pour moi une oeuvre d'art derrière une
oeuvre d'art ya de l'humain faut jamais
l'oublier c'est à dire c'est pas
uniquement
on n'est pas dans une marketing culturel
on a un homme bien vouloir agréer ça
c'est lorsque l'on peut durer combien
ces passages iter non non non
et du coup vous voulez donc créer un
vrai lien tout à fait et pérenne ou pas
et oui quand on met en lien l'artiste et
d'entreprises on sent qu'il ya une
osmose on pourrait les deux parce que je
vous explique roland passer ça on est
vraiment ce lien on est au milieu des
deux est en fait ce qui est très
important c'est que l'artiste drogba
dont le va dans le va visiter winfrey et
vice versa l'entreprise vient dans la
toile et il ya ce qu'on l'entende
important de rencontres de discussions
d'ailleurs virginie après avoir visité
urban logistique à créer de nouvelles
toiles il ya eu une hache ou salaces
incroyable histoire
si on veut en savoir plus vous avez un
site ww art partage pointe comme un
partage fois comme et qui est très
explicite et vous jean luc et bien vous
aussi vous avez un site vous avez par
rapport à votre assurance vie en société
temple hill c'est la même chose et puis
les téléphones qui sont à la disposition
de nos convives vous avez vu tout à
l'heure passée l'habitation
on a transmises très largement sur la
vie nouvelle et donc maintenant on va
faire aussi acte de pédagogie pour
convaincre les entrepreneurs de
participer au financement dollars très
bien mais écoutez bravo bonne chance et
a très vite merci
[Musique]